we need to reject any politics the
targets people because of race or
religion I'm going to try to make it a
little shorter when politicians insult
Muslims and doesn't make us safer it's
just wrong it diminishes us in the eyes
of the world it makes it harder to
achieve our goal we just need to call
them what they are killers and fanatics
who have to be rooted out hunted down
and destroyed because in today's world
even a handful of terrorists replace no
value on human life including their own
can do a lot of damage the United States
of America right now has the strongest
most durable economy in the world gas
under two bucks a gallon ain't bad
either
bye